8 novembre 2016 les etats unis
d'amérique se déchire comme rarement
auparavant
suite à l'annoncé des résultats et
l'élection de donald trump un contraste
saisissant se dessine d'un côté une
ecstasy plein de joie et d'espoir à que
chaleureusement cette nouvelle inespérée
de l'autre des larmes de haine et des
cris de désespoir accompagnera ce point
n'a été aussi divisés les médias
américains sont couverts d'hyperboles
les uns voit enfin la lumière au bout du
tunnel
les autres annoncent le pire et ça remet
déjà pour une lutte de tous les instants
et pendant ce temps les études
sociologiques le confirme
les américains se sont de plus en plus
polarisé
ils se sont complètement isolés dans
l'un des deux camps politiques
la marijuana contre la religion la gay
pride contre la sainteté du mariage
l'avortement contre la vie les aides à
l'international contre le
protectionnisme
les écologistes contre le développement
économique l'interdiction des armes
contre la liberté de les posséder
les hippies contre les conservateurs
l'égalité contre la sécurité
la redistribution des richesses contre
la réduction des charges sur les
entreprises le progrès contre les
traditions les villes contre les
campagnes il ya de bonnes chances que
vous trouviez systématiquement du même
côté du débat n'est ce pas étrange
comment se fait-il que chacun d'entre
nous n'arrivent pas à avoir une opinion
plus mixtes sur tous ces sujets de
société divers et variés comment se
fait-il qu'à partir de une ou deux
réponses à ces questions
les économistes sont souvent capables de
prédire nos réponses ou votre question
je sais ce que vous vous dites vous
dites que tous les gens dans l'autre
camp sont tous stupides que votre camp
et le bon camp que vous avez raison mais
comment se fait-il que des gens stupides
de l'autre camp soient tous d'accord sur
des sujets de société aussi divers et
variés comment se fait-il que des gens
stupides n'est pas des opinions plus
mixte est plus aléatoire
et puis êtes vous sûr que les gens de
votre camp sont tous plus intelligents
que ceux du camp opposé c'est loin
d'être évident le niveau d'éducation
notamment une fois contrôlé vis-à-vis de
facteurs de confusion comme la pression
des pairs du cac dans les cas de
l'élection de 36 états unis
est loin d'être un si bon prédicateur la
position idéologique et puis après tout
l'histoire des sciences et de la
philosophie montre que des gens très
éduquée se retrouve sur un spectre
idéologique très étendue à l'instar de
ce qui se passe aux etats unis quelque
chose semble divisée toutes les sociétés
démocratiques
plus que jamais et les chiffres qui
révèlent cette fracture idéologique sont
effrayants au cours des dix dernières
années les américains se sont de plus en
plus polarisé sous le mandat d'un barack
obama qui disait pourtant vouloir les
unifier sur des questions typique du
débat républicain versus démocrate
les réponses des américains sont de plus
en plus systématiquement celle du parti
avec lequel il s'identifie et cette
scission croissante des idéologies
politiques est encore plus marquée chez
ceux qui sont politiquement actif les
différences géographiques se sont aussi
accentuées les news feed se sont
radicalisées désormais la très grande
majorité des comptes et sont très
nettement remporté que ce soit par un
tempo trad ou républicain pire encore
l'opinion d'un camp au sujet de l'autre
c'est profondément aggravée aujourd'hui
45% des républicains pensent que
l'idéologie démocrate est une menace à
l'avenir des états unis tandis que 41%
des techniques
es tu penses que l'idéologie
républicaine est dangereuse et
l'accession au pouvoir de donald trump
ne semble qu amplifier cette scission
idéologique nationale jeu après jour à
tel point qu'aujourd'hui c'est cette
scission idéologique grandissante qui
m'inquiète le plus je dirais même qu'il
s'agit de l'une de mes plus grandes
inquiétudes pour le futur de l'humanité
je la trouve même peut-être plus
préoccupante que les pires idéologie des
hommes politiques mais mettons mes
tourments de côté et posons-nous l'une
des questions les plus fascinantes qui
soit pourquoi est ce que les gens
pensent ce qu'ils pensent et en
particulier pourquoi est ce qu'ils se
sont polarisés comme ce fut le cas et
surtout que doit-on faire pour des
polariser les convictions politiques
il s'agit là de vastes questions on peut
mentionner en vrac les biais de
confirmation la pression des pairs
l'heuristique de disponibilité du
plaisir de les ans cultive et tout plein
d'autres erreurs logiques tous nos
crétins de cerveaux sont constamment
victimes mais en tant que théoricien des
jeux ce qui m'intéresse ce sont les
causes systémiques en particulièrement à
savoir si modifier la structuration de
nos sociétés pourraient conduire à des
résultats différents
il a bien sûr il ya le phénomène des
faiseurs bugs et des épidémies
idéologique dont on parlera dans des
prochains épisodes est pour aujourd'hui
j'aimerais a avancé une explication qui
n'est que trop peu avancé à mon goût
j'affirme que c'est notre système
démocratique lui-même qui conduit
inéluctablement à l'api polarisation
idéologique de notre société et pour
comprendre pourquoi
revenons en 2002 voici notre estimation
c'est un tremblement de terre qui secoue
la france on est le 21 avril 2002 à la
suite du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle la gauche de lionel
jospin s'est fait éliminer par le front
national de jean marie
le pen jospin humilié par cet échec
monstrueux annonce la fin de sa carrière
politique est soi même et j'en tire les
conclusions en me retirant de la vie
politique après après la fin de
l'élection présidentielle où seront tour
le taux de votants augmente de plus de
10% et jacques chirac deviendra
président a une très très très large
majorité
et pourquoi justement ça qui fait
éliminer au premier tour c'est parce
qu'ils étaient donnés favoris parce que
jospin était favorite personne ne
doutait de sa présence au second tour la
gauche s'est divisée
cette année là le candidat de gauche et
très nombreux mais surtout les électeurs
de gauche ont éparpillé leur vote
l'extrême gauche en particulier a connu
des résultats inhabituellement élevé et
c'est là que réside le paradoxe tragique
de notre système électoral en se
présentant ou en votant ce qu'il voulait
voter les candidats et électeurs de
gauche se sont auto poignardé en
favorisant l' issue qui leur déplaît le
plus à savoir l'absence d'un candidat de
gauche au second tour et c'est pour ça
que l'on a désormais des primaires dans
les deux grands partis politiques
d'aujourd'hui c'est pour éviter
l'éparpillement des voix qu'elle subit
la gauche en 2002 ces primaires sont
devenues tellement courante de nos jours
qu'on ne se pose même plus la question
de leur légitimité de leur pertinence ou
de leur raison d'être dans nos systèmes
démocratiques
tout comme on ne questionne plus
vraiment le fait qu'il n'y ait que deux
grands partis politiques pourtant il est
là le problème de notre système
démocratique parce qu'il n'y a que deux
camps politiques
on est poussé à choisir l'un de ces deux
camps ici cela n'est encore qu'à moitié
vrai en france
outre atlantique c'est on ne peut plus
le cas si c'est encore plus le cas là
bas qu'ici ce n'est pas parce que les
américains sont plus idiot c'est parce
que leurs systèmes les plus davantage à
se dire
c'est en deux camps politiques 10 juin
fera système de vote américain et d'une
complexité atroce est un arbitre r t as
tre je ne vais pas rentrer dans les
détails mais en première approximation
on peut voir qu'il s'agit d'une élection
à un tour
il vous voyez le problème avec
l'élection à un tour l'éparpillement des
voix est un problème bien plus immédiat
ainsi le jour où la démocrate hillary
clinton de 20 candidats à la
présidentielle de 2016 fut le jour où
les idées du démocrate bernie sanders
fleurs tuer dans l'oeuf
pour commencer 6 under se présentait à
son tour ils voleraient des voix clinton
et garantirait quasiment immédiatement
l'élection de trump comme sanders était
idéologiquement plus proche de clinton
que de trump il avait donc tout intérêt
à ne pas se présenter
plus généralement une fois qu'il ya deux
candidats importants tout citoyen a
intérêt à ne pas se présenter
puisque en se présentant il défavorise
le candidat dont il est le plus proche
est favori celui qu'il ne veut
absolument pas voir être élu on dit que
nos scrutins sont dépendants aux
alternatives non pertinente puisque la
présence d'un candidat alternatif
ici bernie sanders va affecter l'issue
du vote et cette dépendance aux
alternatives non pertinente est un fléau
très problématique cause de cela un
scrutin à un tour encore plus qu'un
système de tour conduit inéluctablement
un bipartisme et force chaque citoyen à
choisir un camp
parmi 2 en fait c'est même pire que cela
pour éviter l'élection de trump sanders
a tout intérêt à vanter tous les mérites
du programme de clinton même ceux avec
lequel il est en désaccord et c'est pour
ça que les idées se polarise temps dans
nos systèmes démocratiques par semaine
et inéluctablement dans une élection à
deux camps tout citoyen un intérêt a
annoncé son adhésion complète à l'un des
deux camps même s'il ne préfère en fait
que très légèrement un camp à l'autre et
derrière cela retrouve tout le problème
du dilemme du vote utile dans nos
systèmes démocratiques et mis à la place
que pour deux courants de pensée et vous
avez tout intérêt à choisir vente
pire encore une fois votre camp choisi
vous avez tout intérêt à vanter tous les
aspects de votre camp et ça ça conduit
inéluctablement à une bipolarisation
croissante
idéologie politique qui pousse vers les
extrêmes c'est pour ça que je pense
qu'il est urgent et critique de
considérer des système démocratique
alternatif des systèmes qui ne favorise
pas en tout cas favori ce - le
bipartisme et la clé pour ce faire est
de construire des scrutins qui sont
indépendants aux alternatives non
pertinentes et qui ferme la porte au
dilemme du vote utile
et comme on le verra dans des prochains
épisodes ces cinq grades et
mathématiques démocratie existe me
paraît urgent de les adopter aussi tôt
que possible pour éviter un futur où nos
sociétés se déchirent auront de plus en
plus c'est l'avenir de l'humanité qui
est en jeu la 1ère fois on a lancé cette
série sur la démocratie avec un épisode
où j'ai montré comment le choix d'un
scrutin pouvait complètement déterminé
l'issue du vote cet épisode a été super
bien reçu et ça m'a fait super plaisir
de voir que vous êtes tout aussi excité
que moi par cette nouvelle série de
vidéos youku temps ne fait la remarque
qu'avec les agendas on pouvait lire en
fête tout le monde dans le scrutin
en effet d'ailleurs je vous invite à
essayer de le prouver ne pouvait que
pour tout candidat il existe un agenda
qui fait gagner son candidat je tiens à
signaler qu'il ya même un truc assez
génial dans la vidéo précédente j'étais
tout fier quand j'ai écrit l'épisode que
tout se combine parfaitement qui est le
fait que non seulement on a trouvé un
scrutin et qui élit ravi mais en plus on
a trouvé une façon d'amener ce scrutin
de façon ultra naturel qui donne pas du
tout l'impression que jessica a choisi
le scrutin en question pour faire élire
a ri et c'était vraiment ça le génie de
mesquita dans son bouquin mais là aussi
de trouver ce site de vote et à titre
personnel quand j'ai adapté son exemple
pour la vidéo précédente
j'étais tout fier que tout se
combinaient parfaitement avec les
arguments du sexisme et tout ça je
trouve que ça fait une très belle
histoire
évitez assez fier de mon cou christophe
pirouette nous dit qu'il faudrait sans
doute enseigner cela aux générations
futures
en fait je pense que la théorie des
systèmes de vote notamment ces petits
jeux qui sont très faciles à comprendre
c'est une très très bonne approche aux
mathématiques déjà quelque chose de très
concret très ludique lugano et qui fait
réfléchir pendant commence à se poser
les questions pendantes essayer de
prouver que tout le monde pouvait être
élu par agenda de cisco était un
précédent commence à ressembler à une
démonstration mathématique petit à petit
et des grosses mathématiques qui se
cache derrière tout ça donc oui je serai
carrément pour enseigner duke a quelques
idées derrière la théorie des systèmes
de vote et la théorie des jeux en
général aux enfants dès leur plus jeune
âge je pense que ça leur parlera un peu
plus que la trigonométrie kembs lehmann
se pose la question de savoir ce que
c'est une bonne idée d'être neutre dans
ces vidéos notamment je suis sûr qu'il
ya pas mal parmi vous qui se disent il
n'a pas dit de mal je trouve quelque
chose comme ça donc je tiens d'ailleurs
le dire à voix haute je suis créera
aussi dans les commentaires mais je
supprimerai tous les commentaires qui
font référence à l'actualité ou qui
mentionne un candidat à la
présidentielle et prend parti pour un
des candidats vous autorise à parler des
candidats notamment de trump
c'est pas trop quoi pour analyser de
façon assez neutre ce qui s'est passé ou
des choses comme ça mais dès que vous
prenez partie que ce soit pro ou anti
trust ce sera supprimée des commentaires
j'ai envie vraiment qu'on ait une
discussion sur les systèmes politique et
non pas sur les personnalités de la
politique ou quoi que ce soit l'objectif
n'est pas du tout être impartiale parce
que ces vidéos ne sont pas du tout
impartial je suis totalement partial par
exemple je suis contre ce scrutin retour
se fait contre le scrutin à deux tours
je suis pas du tout impartial pas du
tout quoi je suis un gros problème
aujourd'hui avec la politique ce n'est
pas les idéologies d un épisode c'est le
fait que ça divise du cac c'est une de
mes plus grosses inquiétudes et c'est
vraiment un des trucs contre lesquels je
vais essayer de lutter dans ces vidéos
j'ai envie qu'on soit un peu mois se
divise et qu'on sait de mieux comprendre
les avis des uns et des autres et je
justifierait d'ailleurs pourquoi est-ce
que prendre une position aussi une autre
que possible sans doute la meilleure
façon de faire en utilisant des
arguments venant de la théorie des jeux
notamment comme le dit arrache z
je vais déjà voir sans doute beaucoup de
trolls dans mes commentaires
j'ai pas envie qu'ils aient des trolls
en plus qu'ils essaieraient de trolley
vis-à-vis de trucs qui ne sont pas le
coeur du message de mes vidéos
elle espère que j'avais cette vidéo la
prochaine soit on va parler de théorèmes
d'impossibilité
des mathématiques de la démocratie comme
beaucoup l'ont fait remarquer dans les
commentaires de la vidéo précédente il
ya déjà eu d'excellentes vidéo de
sciences étonnante de la statistique a
expliqué à mon chat sur ces histoires
des systèmes de vote et je vous
recommande fortement d'aller les voir
ceux qui n'ont pas l'habitude de cette
folle et qui ont des inquiétudes part ça
vous inquiétez pas on va parler de pas
mal de choses donc tim donc parler ne
vous inquiétez pas ça va pas être ultra
répondant par rapport à ceux qui sont
déjà je pense que cette vidéo là de
montrer que j'ai abordé quand même chose
d'une façon assez différent de la
manière dont ils ont abordé leur propre
vidéo
j'en profite aussi pour vous recommander
très fortement les deux vidéos que j'ai
un lien vidéo de six figuraient sur
place pas de pause pour que le système
et je vous conseille aussi la vidéo de
the good stuff et explique vraiment que
les statistiques montrent que les états
unis sont plus divisés que jamais si
vous avez aimez cette vidéo pensez à la
ligue et à la commenter à la partager
pensez à vous abonner pour ne pas
manquer les futurs épisodes de mercy au
keeper power donc et j'espère que je
verrai la prochaine fois